yo it's the bullet cap podcast bullet
cap show special guest my guy in here
boston's finest
millie's is here cambridge specifically
you got to help me out 617. you know i
love boston i went to lawrence once and
dj'd and there was some lovely puerto
rican women in that city many ghanas
yeah
yeah that was uh that was in lawrence
that's where nikki jam is from
is that where uh term's from that's what
terms from too yeah
so what's up man
good luck i've been you've been grinding
bro yeah
talk to me i mean obviously you got the
album coming out in the 20s but i feel
like you just been so active the last
couple of years since the last time we
we we saw each other the last time you
did the show i just feel like you've
been on your campaign [ __ ] just going
crazy
yeah when did i do the show that was
that was 2019 2018
yeah it was when uh you were i think at
the time that's when i was still getting
solidified with the barge like yeah i
mean i've been solidified but that's
when i was checking off all the
platforms like i think at that time
enough was helping out a little bit
behind the scenes
hell yeah but yeah no i mean i feel like
uh the last
year and some chat i feel i really feel
like you've been thriving during the
pandemic bro yeah now the pandemic did
it the pandemic did it because what the
pandemic did it even the playing field
for me so whereas like a rapper that's
already booming and doing festivals you
could get all that type of content right
every day your social media looks crazy
you jumping in crowds and um marsh pits
and and you're next to kylie jenner
after parties the pandemic leveled the
whole playing field because now you
can't do that so now you got to compete
with me
song for song video for video
bar for bar and i'm gonna i'll do that
you know i mean i'll do you on that so i
feel like that's where i thrive at yeah
i always say like i feel like for
artists who actually can rap the
pandemic
did wonders because
everyone's listening differently they're
listening at the crib they're listening
to their airpods or they're listening
driving in their car as opposed to being
at the club standing on a [ __ ] couch
yeah digesting like microwavable
[ __ ]
yeah it took out it took out all like
the the bubble gum [ __ ] for a while
you're thriving freddie gibbs was
thriving all the griselda's on a run
during the pandemic like i feel like the
bars are like
with the what the [ __ ] that just
happened with the locks kisses at the
height of the rap game it's amazing it's
like so harass me it feels like nas got
the number one album on itunes like i
just feel like it's we're kind of like
low-key in like a renaissance of like
dope rap again yeah
a lot of the bullshit's out the window
right now yeah hell yeah
you feel that way too
not 100 i feel like um
it's high level rap you know what i mean
high level rap is is what high level rap
is longevity like that [ __ ] never goes
away you got that skill set it'll never
ever go away you know as far as like
you'll always have a core audience
because you have that skill set
it's like
you know being able to
to uh like like be a chef or some [ __ ]
like you know how to cook like that'll
always that'll always be helpful in some
capacity
some other [ __ ] just comes and goes if
you think of like who's been here
forever and who it is all the rappers
nobody that's what i believe
drake is a
elite emcee hell yeah high level rapper
kendrick j cole rap all high level
rappers
yeah nah that's facts man we think about
who's been around 20 25 years in the
danish yeah but it wasn't the trendy
[ __ ] right
you know so sometimes they they i felt
like they would even like people would
look down on it like oh yo you got bars
like try to cast that to the side nah
[ __ ] i got bars yeah
i could be here forever you can't yeah
enjoy your summer yeah yeah get hot
that's why i don't trip when i see
people like surpass me or whatever it
might be like a younger artist and he
gets on and he has a crazy two years but
i know i'm gonna i got this [ __ ] forever
forever forever and i only get better
give me uh some of your background like
like obviously coming out of
massachusetts um
when did you start rapping like when did
you start actually recording music going
to the studio taking [ __ ] kind of
serious um
i've been doing this a long time bro
like i've been
i've been rapping since like 2010 even
2008 for real
like but 2016 i started putting my whole
soul into it and taking a serious
serious serious cause i like moved to
new york i got some baggage off of me
like when i was when i was rapping
before i just had a lot of other [ __ ]
connected to it like street [ __ ] and
whatever was going on so that would kind
of you know um direct one foot in one
foot out yeah and um just being attached
to massachusetts but when i when i moved
to new york it was like i kind of took a
step back to take a step forward
i had to um compromise
um
like my living comfortability and [ __ ]
like that like you know what i mean i
had to um
i had like i moved to new york i moved
to the bronx in a roach infested
apartment
and started over right there with no
network i just knew set free that was
the only person i knew in new york and i
started just building my network over
time there from the ground up and i
think that was in 2013 and then in 2016
i finally um
i cracked the bt cypher i was able to do
that and then she started going for me
so you had to kind of like what what
made you make the decision to get out of
your comfort zone and leave was it
because you were involved in some
[ __ ] back home and you felt like no
i feel like i hit a glass ceiling
because i was always i always been lit
where i'm from like in my state i've
been getting paid for features for 10
plus years you know what i mean i've
been in the newspapers i did summer jam
i was always him where i was jamming
summer jam yeah jam in summer jam i was
always him where i was from so it's like
i hit this glass ceiling and it just
felt like i was a big fish in a small
pond i wanted more i would go i would
take these trips i would go to like
you know south by southwest or whatever
it was or
different [ __ ] in new york and people
wouldn't know me like that
you know i have to yeah you got to see
things how they are not how you want
them to be i'll be like damn i'm not
really that lit
and so that's what made me move to new
york and then it just so happened that
like when i was out there i realized i
could commit to being a a full artist
like
completely in totality boston has always
kind of had like an interesting scene
there's always been a scene there right
there's been guys like obviously static
selected to me is like kind of the go to
the last like 10 or 15 years
one of the greatest producers ever shout
out to static but i just mean like you
know cousins
uh i think it was michael christmas is
from out there
um my people there's uh was mike stud
from boston
she from providence i don't know but you
know there was always there's always
artists that are active in the city but
i always feel like boston has like as
like a there's never been like a
movement on the mainstream you know what
i'm saying part of the problem is that
like boston is a small part of
massachusetts which is but but it gets
credit for the whole massachusetts facts
so like i mean look i was like yeah we
got boston's face yeah
that [ __ ] is annoying you know what i
mean but it's like everybody looks at
the whole mass if you look at boston
actually on the map it's like a small
part of massachusetts right so it's like
we got springfield
lawrence lowell
worcester
uh lynn cambridge you know what i mean
all these different places that produce
talent
but i feel like now um
that's shout out to beer too i i got a
shout out yeah like yeah yeah
now joiner we got joyner yeah
but uh i feel like um
i feel like that like boston just had
like a stigma with it because when you
think of like boston you think of like
white people and racism and [ __ ] like
certain like it's hard to break in to
understand how much culture is in that
city
like the dorchesters or roxburys and
matapians and [ __ ] like that like
but yeah i think it was hard for people
to um understand that good music was
being made out of boston or out of
massachusetts but we're pushing the
massachusetts movement now it's a lot of
talent out there do you think that that
is a uh misconception about the area the
racist [ __ ] cause we always hear that
about
the sports fans out of massachusetts the
you know we you know now it's not a it's
not a misconception but it's it's two
sides to to everything right you know
what i mean
that's what i would say like like that
exists but that's not the only thing
that of course they exist like i've
never been in the td garden and heard
somebody say some racist [ __ ] right
personally that's wha
there was that uh the the big
controversy about uh
which player stepped on the damn celtics
guy
and then big baby davis came and spoke
up on it killed kyrie irving yeah kg
spoke up on it there was all this yeah
well how'd you feel when that happened
i mean because that's a historic i would
i feel like sometimes we get a little
too overly sensitive these days to where
it's like guys you know like we're
talking about basketball like the logo
is a little leprechaun but like not
everything gotta be connected to the
race he did what he was supposed to do
yeah i don't i didn't take it on no
racist [ __ ] i just took it like he was
saying [ __ ] the celtics i mean yeah he
had a bad you know two years in boston
for whatever reason i mean a lot of it
was probably on him but you know that's
neither here nor there um
you and and jadakiss obviously [ __ ]
with so raspy kisses you know one of the
most
just down to earth coolest dudes in the
rap game um if you know him you know
he's just you know he's just he's humble
and i feel like he's always trying to
help out whoever he [ __ ] with even if
it's not awesome like you're signing me
[ __ ] he's always
doing records with up-and-coming artists
he watches definitely what's it like
working with kiss
just in general having him as your big
homie man
it's dope man it's like like the kiss
that people saw on verses i see that
every day facts yeah people think like
did he
i don't know like that that's some new
[ __ ] for him no that's how he acts on
his block with like 100 homies around
100 way he cracks jokes and all of that
like and then like yeah he he um
he's just for the culture man like he
he's a real rapper bro at the core and
are you are you signing his label yeah
i'm down with kiss since i i i've been
down with kiss for a minute yeah but
like officially like 2017.
yeah it's crazy because i feel like that
versus moment like you said it kind of
like reminded a lot of people like yo
kisses they don't say top five dead or
alive and for no reason you know what
i'm saying just to burn any
rapper his age right now oh 100 no i
mean any rapper i mean i right now give
any rapper and i got the utmost respect
the utmost respect
for whole
naz
am
kiss will give each one of them a 16 on
the same beat kiss will burn them i can
agree with you there that's a fact for
sure i think too hove might
stand a chance no just just in that bar
for him like nah
i'm talking about 16 16 16 bars with the
goats with all of the goats these are
the goats that's why i'm you know
talking about them but kisses burning
[ __ ] i just think too like with that
versus i was telling everybody before it
happened i was like man the one thing
people are not factoring into this
battle is
the locks still actually [ __ ] with each
other they're still actually chemistry
chemistry camaraderie chemistry these
guys are still with each other my man
right there reem scully's hurt hurt he
thought
he still hurt he's been on twitter
saying that he wanted to do a rematch on
live and the the songs that they match
he's hurt you know a lot of people were
hurt by that
you know what though
hellox
is this baby a lot of people that's
acting like they don't know kisses of
gold
already
now people people but
now but you know what the difference is
now is
now listen the difference is kiss
this versus has done something that no
other verses really has done and i feel
like now
i was on academic [ __ ] right now and
they just posted a kiss verse he did
with dream doll and said is this the
verse of the year i'm like that [ __ ]
ain't happening you know now like the
younger kids who might not have known
the pedigree that jadakiss when they did
that [ __ ]
yo man but y'all ain't got nothing for
them females
oh man it was a murder and when when
kiss came back with the female bag oh my
god they did the jenny from the block
and the i said
this this is embarrassing at this point
we got greens
y'all got grams
listen i love dip set and like on the
surface i can see
how you could be like i got dipset
winning the battle before it happened
but once you really start thinking like
man
janet was on i mean the locks were on
you know life after death they were on
it's dark and hell is hot you know what
i'm saying like this is different
it's a different bag it's just a whole
different bag there to watch g unit
i think so walsh
i think so
it's undebatable
and it would have been nice
and it would have been fire yeah
but the thing is is that camaraderie but
then i don't know like you like
50's tough to wash but long he don't
need g unit 50 just needs to stand on
stage and talk [ __ ] 50 could just play
get rich or die trying from front to
back
and just have the mic and just troll
people that's the one thing i would love
to see jada and 50 on stage just just
just throwing shots at each other
because they were both hilarious
type [ __ ]
but i was like i was so disappointed
with cab i was expecting cab to say some
funny [ __ ] i was like man anytime jim
jones was performing his [ __ ] cameron
was in the back with like the aunt i was
like damn
styles was with kids like they was with
each other that [ __ ] was historical
though
nah what i love now listen man
they were in the crowd i wasn't gonna do
that was nothing because when they were
not because when they paid him
hey what i love man we gotta
when they played the street [ __ ] they
played that bird gang [ __ ] over there
they played that bird gang [ __ ]
but they can't the stack bundles was
bird gang now they dipsticked
it
nah man hey man shout out to jim shout
out to cam i love dipset but it was a
definitive l man um so who all do you
have on this new album you would you say
you got g herbo
kiss
i got herbo i got kiss i got asian doll
i got benny the butcher
i got donna the dealer
[Music]
8-zip from boston and why drizzle from
boston
you put out a video asian doll right
yeah i saw that that's kind of a random
collab yeah yeah yeah didn't see that
one coming yeah we met we met in a crazy
way we met um
we met in a strip club in illinois i was
literally about to say i bet you better
at a strip club yeah you know that
we met in a strip club in atlanta
and um
and and and i was i was with my people
who knew her and we left out
and i had the culling in the
the the rose truck or whatever and we
all jumped in the rose truck and we were
gonna go to the next spot and then shots
just started going off
like little machine gun fire and [ __ ]
and um and i'm bent i'm smacked you know
what i'm saying that my man is like yo
get down get out the car get down
but i feel like the shots aren't too
close to me type [ __ ] so i just i get
out the car or whatever
i get down but like before i do that
like i just look in the passenger side
and like asian dogs just in the
passenger side like fixing her makeup in
the mirror unfazed while the shots are
going off
look i'm like
[ __ ] ends
i'm like yo you doing your makeup while
the shots was going off like man i'm
trying to get to my next destination
some [ __ ] like that it's like oh no
she's different and then we locked this
since then so yeah
yeah she did a freestyle for us a couple
years ago that was she was fine it was
solid yeah it was good she's fine
surprisingly she's fire but she was uh i
think she used to be with gucci right
g herbo
fire yeah
benny that's i mean herbo [ __ ] came from
high level rap too because he um he
posted my um
bars on nine five freestyle but i had
known herbo since um smokers club tour
right right right
but he posted my um
my uh bars on nine five freestyle
and then i just knew like ah he gonna
give me a record
let's do it we did that [ __ ] out here so
that was fire it's going to be my
quickest million are you going to do
another um you did a collab tape with
dave is there another artist you would
want to do a collab tape with or someone
who you're talking to
i don't know like i never met him but i
wanted to do a collab table with mazzy
though that would be hard oh yeah with
mozzie because he got like ball work i
like some of the mozzie can wrap his ass
off and he got pain yes yeah like he's
one of my favorite rappers in the world
i want to lock him with mozzie have you
you haven't met mazzy yet no but um we
got mutual people though i want him to
lock him with mazzy that's that's about
it
that'd be crazy i'd like to do some [ __ ]
with young ma too
she's fire
that's like the type of rappers that i
i like you know what i mean i mean i'm
so glad the rappers they could rap but
they still i like that i just love east
coast people tapping with mozzie because
i feel like he's oh no he's high level
hey high level mc and i just don't think
like outside of like over here he i feel
like he should get more respect in those
conversations you know what i'm saying
hey interrupting the interview to tell
you about our good friends at odd socks
now as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying oh shout out to my
bony ass knees um listen go to
oddssocksofficial.com they got all the
craziest socks these are the outsiders
you know what i'm saying they got
spongebob they got cheech and chong
listen breaking bad godfather
whatever you need they got it and now
they have underwear that's right you can
get your odd socks underwear the boxer
briefs are the best underwear that you
could ever fit on your ass trust me when
i tell you
these are chucky draws
what you know about top ramen underwear
all right go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev at checkout
and you'll save 20 off of of your order
underwear masks slippers
socks whatever you need they got it
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
habit kevin checkout save 20 yo you have
a relationship with shoddy right yes sir
um
how's he doing are you still in contact
with him he's doing great
every day i talk to him he just says uh
another day at the office man
getting some getting some rest working
out it's another day at the office yeah
that's uh you know there's this this
whole situation that he's been a part of
just kind of got reignited online with
this whack 100 interview and a lot of
that stuff kind of what's your take on
on you know
it seems to be like i feel like there's
some sort of
part of the industry that's starting to
try to push 69 back in our face a little
bit i felt like [ __ ] had kind of got put
to bed after he put his [ __ ] out and it
kind of flopped but like kind of what's
your thoughts on what's going on right
now with all that [ __ ]
it's a rat
a rodent
i don't know like i don't i don't even
be i don't even be watching this [ __ ] he
do or whatever this is that's like you
know he sent people to jail he took
people away from their kids man like
you're right he eroded he just scum of
the earth bro there's no that's like me
sitting here and discussing a pedophile
like you already know what it is like
that he is a because i think that that's
what the one thing whack was saying no
he's a rat he's a rat yeah because whack
was like he's a civilian who told the
truth
once you do a street act that takes you
out of that discussion
you consciously do a street act yeah no
yeah that's what you're not a civilian
no more that's what glasses you choose
to pick up a gun and walk outside right
now you know what's coming out of the
civilian no more that's a illegal crime
you're a criminal yeah
yeah no that's kind of uh you know
shout out to my guy she's a rodent g
malone out here that's kind of what he
just wrote it
once you once you knowingly do something
criminal hell yeah and you are doing it
involved in that life and you got to
know what that [ __ ] comes with right
period now if you're a celebrity it's
called accountability
and i don't even [ __ ] with people who
aren't accountable in the real normal
life yeah in normal life let alone when
people's lives are on the line
and you sending [ __ ] to jail
because you're not accountable for your
actions [ __ ] out of it scum of the earth
there it is he's a broken man he i mean
you know i'm saying like you you got
broken you
you let them people break you
that's it i got homies doing natural
life right now but they're not broken
they could look in the mirror
every day
still call me in high spirits type [ __ ]
when when when shotty was running with
with six nine and you were cool with him
when he was out of jail was there ever
any conversations about like watch out
for that guy because i think obviously
he had rainbow hair he seemed to be
extremely extravagant online from the
jump
no i never i never um i never went
around him like that like i had been
around him on like the video set of like
the um to get the strap [ __ ] with 50
cent or whatever
but that was like the furthest extent of
it but what i do know is shoddy really
loved him though
and shot he put in a lot of pain behind
him
but like shoddy really loved him like
intimate conversations from me with me
and shoddy where i knew like before all
that [ __ ] hit the fan he's like nah i
love that dude man i'll rush my life for
that dude like shoddy loved that kid
they were like they had a genuine
connection hell yeah bro he would have
went to the end of the earth protect
that kid he would have did whatever he
could
to make that kid be successful and and
that and that he did that kid knows that
[ __ ] and he did yeah when i went to the
i went to the um to to his sentencing
and um because shady used to always tell
me i used to ask him like yo uh
because he was trying to sign me and we
were trying to figure it out like if we
could mix the trayway [ __ ] with the
raspberry [ __ ] or whatever and um he
would always ask me i mean i would
always ask him like yo what about the
feds bro like the feds coming for y'all
and they'd be like hell no milly's man i
ain't the crime in so long he's like you
know i mean [ __ ] like that but then when
we was at his
sentencing
like the judge
listed off all the pain he put in
and i mean like every two months it was
something and i was like damn bro like
you were really going crazy he was like
yeah i should have been more hands off
you know what i mean but
he was putting in pain for that kid does
that make like when you see [ __ ] like
that or i mean obviously there's been i
feel like hip-hop is under a microscope
with the feds for some reason right now
like
do you do you
not only on that but this is why not to
cut you off this is why it's under a
microscope with the feds because if you
think about it right
all right you will
you a federal officer or some [ __ ] you
you got to bring your boss some cases
right so you got these dudes over here
selling this doing this you got these
dudes over here telling us doing this
and then you got these dudes over here
selling us doing this but they're
connected to a successful rapper
whose case is your boss gonna take he's
gonna take the one with the successful
rapper because that's just gonna hit the
media and then it makes like it's like
your pr campaign is done for you also
it's probably easier to get those guys
because not for nothing
it's a lot of self snitching going on on
the internet
in the hip hop world
yeah but they'll be taking [ __ ] out of
context too like i'll be seeing some of
these kids from jacksonville and i'm
like man where is their team cause
they're there's like bodies piling up
out there and these [ __ ] is
like on the internet making records and
i'm like bro what is going on
like
you know like i feel like do you feel
like there's like certain things you
won't share online or sharing bars or
sharing records because even if it's
fictional even if it's some hip-hop [ __ ]
you're afraid that maybe like how it
might get taken out of context if there
were ever be a situation like that
i don't involve myself in any crime
whatsoever
so
no what about um
you know moving around because you
you're i always see you everywhere bro
you're in atlanta you in l.a you move
around nicely in colombia i'm the only
white rabbit that does that too but i
was gonna say like you know there's been
so many people getting caught slipping
whether it's nip whether it's uh king
vaughn whatever it is how how careful
are you when you're moving around
outside of your like where you're from i
mean listen you have a
this is probably the biggest
entrepreneur she's had in a while
[Laughter]
so there it is very careful we got it we
got to protect the brand
i've never been like i've been rapping
like
15 10 10 15 years like you know i
nothing ever happened to me in that
whole time that's fair and it's not
gonna like
you know that that's just how i wake up
and feel every day
who was your when you were like when you
were growing up listening to hip-hop
being a kid from massachusetts who was
like that artist you looked up to in
your city that made you feel like
oh [ __ ] it's possible to make it out of
here i saw um i saw a smoke bulger
in the in the newspaper you ever heard
him
smoke bulger he was a big rapper when i
was coming up fact and he still he's got
to deal with rick ross right now
so smoke vulgar inspired me i was at my
school i used to go to school this
little sped school in charlestown and i
got the boston herald one morning and i
looked at it and he was on like like one
of the front pages
that inspired me
and other than that i don't know like
nobody was really
nobody was really cause you probably
came up after like the maids man like
cousins
inspired me like later on in life yeah
he's killing it he's dope man he's a
good dude too yeah that's my brother so
you know but but people but like joyner
inspires me be it inspires me
anybody anybody who's popping out of
massachusetts inspires me because it's
one of the hardest places to make it out
of i think we're changing that slowly
but
if you may if you made it to some sort
of national popularity fame like i
salute you because
you you did good you did great you moved
obviously
static had to move to new york do you
feel like for any kids who are listening
from your city from your state that are
watching this do you think it's a smart
play for them to you know get out of the
comfort zone and maybe yeah but only
when you get booming in mass you still
got to get booming in mass conquer home
first yeah
you still got to be played on the launch
pad with e-double and chevy tub you
still gotta you got to be known if your
name isn't no when i left massachusetts
at least 75 of the whole [ __ ] state
knew my name you know what i mean you
had already done what you could do like
if you don't know me you may be a
freshman in college going to one of
these schools and you from iowa or
something but like blue collar
massachusetts people knew i was so i got
to that level and then i moved
and i feel like even like
like like being moved when she got the
deal with pharrell so if you get a deal
and you gotta move or something but
yeah i feel like you should move out of
mass after you after you conquer it you
know what i mean what is uh in your
opinion the best
boston movie because there's some
amazing ones they departed
i was in town no i'm [ __ ] with the
town you're going to the town over the
party i'm [ __ ] with the town cause
slain's in the town the slain's my god
jane's the homie yeah and that [ __ ] was
just flavor like i couldn't the the dude
because i grew up with them type of
dudes
like in cambridge just like my
neighborhood was mostly black but then
there's like um
like a part of campus called east
cambridge and it's like those tough type
of white boys and then i went to school
in charlestown where they made that
movie so i grew up with those type of
dudes and jeremy renner when i found out
he was australian my mind was blown
because he killed him because he did
[ __ ] good kid he did great
yeah he did great he did [ __ ] good
kid yeah it's it's crazy because if you
like actually know people from boston
and then you watch a movie where they're
trying to do the boston accent
and not everybody has that [ __ ]
i don't have that like you don't have
the heavy uh getting the [ __ ] car get
in the [ __ ] car dude yeah yo
something something about i did good
right there i think you did i mean i
think you can hit it bro
shout out every time i go to boston and
dj bro
and there's like the drunk boston white
chicks i'll just be weak as [ __ ] the way
they be talking yeah
yo can you play some [ __ ] pitbull
play some [ __ ] people dude
shout out to boston man
um is this going to be the only project
you dropped after you're going to drop
this project next friday is are you done
for the rest of the year just working
the album you got some other [ __ ] right
i'm gonna probably work the album for
the yeah i might drop some more music
but
yeah like this this [ __ ] is like a
home-cooked meal this is soul food like
this is this is it man this is the
culmination of everything that's
happened over this pandemic for me so
yeah i feel like you like i said man i
mean you've been shooting videos for
every [ __ ] thing oh yeah shout out my
man teams like i feel like god gave me
like a a videographer to that's what i
needed
somebody who could run around with me
same ambition and drive shoot my [ __ ]
get it out there because like we got
[ __ ] with
eight hundred thousand and damn near a
million views that we just [ __ ]
freestyled like just shot like hey let's
shoot a video like right now we didn't
run out last night before i did the
other press thing that i did we um we
were in the parking lot we just started
shooting the video because he's nice
like that so it's like i feel like
that's people being able to see me in
that capacity took me to the level
a videographer is important one thing
you vibe with i mean that's like a
videographer producer
videographer
producer
good engineer do you have like a like
in-house production team you work with i
work with this kid ray beets he's from
albania
he's 16 years old he lives in albania
shout out to bronson he sends me a beat
every morning wow he did the asian dog
[ __ ] he did the g herbo [ __ ] he did the
jada record he did the benny record he's
disgusting bro he's 16 years old 16 year
old kid in albania albania
the albanian goat hey albania low-key uh
and music is poppin they got bam bam
they got
dua lipa gashi yeah they doing their
thing man oh yeah they got ray beats too
shout out and then they got ray beats
damn it yeah
shout out to ray
okay let's let's we we conquered so the
town is the best boston movie ever hell
yeah
i'm right it's valid okay how about this
blue hill ave yeah if you want to go to
the other side of boston blue hill ave
i haven't seen that that's the moon
yeah that's that's that's that's the
dream without the other real side of
boston like blue blue hill i have got
nothing to do with the town um
what's the joint with uh
the one that popped off matt damon and
ben affleck
hunting that's i mean that was a good
movie i mean it's cool i like that
gangster [ __ ] i mean we're talking
gangster movies it's different yeah okay
what about this
who if you if you had if you had your
opportunity to have a meal
with any boston legend ever i mean
there's so many legends from the city of
boston i mean they didn't even got
people to be from boston it could be
larry bird it could be ben affleck it
could be
matt damon there's so many legends from
the city of boston if you could have a
meal with one of them like pick the
all-time goat that you would want to sit
down with from your city
i sit down with me i don't know come on
man who
damn i don't know man david ortiz kg oh
yeah i'd get some blantonos with david
ortiz or some [ __ ] like i feel like
that's not that's no if you're going
athletes like no i mean anybody you
don't got to be just athletes but you're
saying people from there no i said it's
got to be a boston legend they don't got
it necessarily okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
hey kg and i know kg but i still sit
down for dinner with him because he's
just who he is
kg yeah kevin garnett facts you got the
celtics tattoo right yeah how you
feeling about uh you know dennis
schroeder going over to the celtics for
that 5.9 man they should have signed my
dog isaiah thomas man for real they did
isaiah dirty though
hey but you know what um he just put up
81 points in the uh the wreck game and
um i guess he's still good for 15 a
night in the league
i could see it he gave him a little
10-day contract and he came back and was
putting up 15. he's like black bold or
something i swear to god i could see the
celtics bringing them back trying to
because danny ainge ain't there no more
i feel like he's blackballed in the nba
yeah i mean the celtics i feel like had
a bit of a uh the offseason was was
underwhelming
brad stevens is running this [ __ ] now
they kind of shipped out i mean dennis
schroeder for 5 million now but next
year we're going to do good next year
though i think that's what they're
they're they're trying to grab something
like bradley bill or something like that
we'll see
y'all we're supposed to get a.d too all
that planning and not trading them draft
picks
never got a.d but we're competitive
every year what team you wrote for the
sons hey we was in the finals yeah
this was y'all first time in the finals
we've been in the conference finals hey
we've been won zero rings yeah
zero so listen you have the you have the
most
probably historically successful
franchise because if you really want to
go with the lakers those minneapolis
rings don't count them that's covered
ring don't count the celtics to me are
the most
historically successful french i mean
like you said
the year uh kyrie was out they went to
the eastern conference no to the when
isaiah thomas was there we were to the
conference finals like we go we got i
think tatum been to the conference
finals
three years if i'm not mistaken and he
only played for like four or five years
yeah shout out to tatum um anything else
man obviously i know you uh you know are
you gonna start get [ __ ] with
anything outside of the hip hop [ __ ]
like maybe acting or just i was just
riding through here looking at all like
the big movie signs and [ __ ] and i was
like yeah like i i gotta get in that
dude you could get your slain on for
sure definitely you gotta plug me in you
could be like the new go-to goon in
boston gangster movies that'd be hot
yeah i like that you just said hard
hard you know what i'm saying you got it
you just that was it
yeah yeah yeah i could do acting
anything else though like you're like
are you like investing are you like
getting you're feeding anything besides
the rap [ __ ] right now you just focused
on popping the rap [ __ ] off yeah i mean
i got i got high level rap right now so
that's like something that like me and
east kind of came up with the concept
hlr
and um it's kind of like a fraternity
but we're coming with the merch
you know high level rap high level life
high level high level high lifestyle rap
you know all that um but but that's a
brand i wanna i wanna um
[Music]
create something bigger for that whether
it's an app or something of that nature
but yeah high level rap is the movement
so who's your starting five mcs right
now excluding yourself just in all the
wrap if we're talking high level rap
starting five
take davies out the conversation too
like alive yeah just right now no no
who's just doing it right now i'm not
talking about all time alive we taking
east out the convo taking yourself out
the car are we taking kiss out the carvo
i mean you can put kiss
i'm just saying my who's on fight like
like let's say the most active
current rappers jadis one of them yeah
he's number one he's the hottest rapper
right now i don't disagree um
conway
benny
tim who else is nice
like i said i like mozzie
mazzy's in there
um herbo there it is yeah that's a nice
star in five
yeah all parts of the all parts of the
country yeah i feel like i'm forgetting
somebody but
that's a that's a solid five though
solid well look the album comes out next
friday yes sir
go get that [ __ ] uh you can go get the
merch and all that [ __ ] going up
yeah the merch is going crazy any tour
[ __ ] coming up
maybe i got some dates with conway on
the road
um i don't think i announced that so i'm
announcing that hell yeah i got i got a
few dates on the conway tour and then um
i got some other shows but i got to see
how this kova [ __ ] plays out yeah i just
saw uh
one of the homies uh chris webby just
canceled his whole tour over the covet
[ __ ] he was supposed to go on tour with
dizzy wright and uh
they were like the mandates are too
crazy we don't ask our fans because a
lot of the venues you got to be
vaccinated to go in oh yeah he don't he
don't play that vaccinated [ __ ] and so
he was in colorado he was like
[ __ ] vaccinations
90 000 people put their hands up like
yeah
yeah he's different
shout out chris webby great guy man yeah
great guy boy yeah yeah yeah great guy
well look man appreciate you pulling up
and then we're gonna do a freestyle so
there's gonna be another youtube video
where he's doing high level bars yeah
boom